welcome back 47 I trust you found your
time in Paris successful the agency has
located your second Target in the
Italian coastal town of
Sapienza we have learned that Gary Lun
formerly known as the enforcer for the
sevo 6 is working at The Ether
Corporation biolab supervising high
level
[Music]
security this is an exclusive holiday
destination 47 and the agency would
discourage a public
elimination although the target was part
of the same sarda paramilitary unit as
Scott Sano there is no indication that
he has learned of his colleagues
[Music]
death L is likely to be found in
luxurious Villa Caruso or The Ether
biolab you should expect access to these
areas to be restricted and a laboratory
security to be particularly heavy I'll
leave you to prepare good
[Music]
luck